we got this one from Fox News ladies and
gentlemen this is probably the biggest
bombshell out of the Devon Archer
testimony I mean that's actually hard to
say because we know that uh in this
testimony we learned Joe Biden was on
the phone 20 plus times with in these
business meetings while VP but this one
is shocking Devin Archer says Hunter
Biden and barisma execs called DC to get
Ukrainian prosecutor fired Devin Archer
testified for hours
Devon Archer testified Monday that
Hunter Biden top execs called DC in 2015
to ask the Obama Administration to help
fire the Ukrainian prosecutor
investigating the firm a source familiar
with his testimony told Fox News digital
and they lied but ladies and gentlemen
we got Joe Biden right here admitting to
all of it happened to be that was that
was Simon I got I I got all the good
ones and so I got Ukraine and uh
um I remember going over convincing our
team our brothers to convincing us that
we should be providing for loan
guarantees and I went over right I guess
the 12th 13th time to Kiev and uh and I
was supposed to announce that there was
another billion dollar loan guarantee
and I had gotten a commitment from
poroshenko and from uh yatsenyuk that
they would take action against the state
prosecutor and they didn't so they said
they had they were walking out to
Prescott said no I said I'm not going to
or we're not going to give you the
billion dollars
they said you have no Authority you're
not the president the president said I
said call him
I said I'm telling you you're not
getting a billion dollars Jesus I said
you're not getting a billion I'm going
to be leaving here and I think it was
what six hours I looked I said I'm
leaving in six hours if the prosecutor
is not fired you're not getting the
money oh son of a I got fired and
there it is right there shout out to DC
Drano for that video which has been
circulating some time he reposted it
today so uh that argument we heard over
and over again from liberals that it was
just U.S policy to fire that prosecutor
now I gotta say that that was never
backed up by anything why why did the
U.S want the prosecutor fired so I I
argued about this like years ago
whenever this came out with a kind of a
mainstream liberal friend of mine and he
said what you just said he was like you
know the entire like everyone in in like
the U.S
establishment agreed that this guy had
to go and this kind of debunks that he
it's saying barisma gave him a call and
said no no so the impetus came from
barisma but this makes sense if you look
at barisma as an arm of U.S interests
barisma acting as U.S policy interests
called DC and says if you want us to
keep operating this guy's got to go
because he's investigating us so simply
put you could say it was U.S policy
there was a former CIA director on the
board of barisma as well as the vice
president's son so of course it was our
policy we were running the show
but when you get to the brass tacks of
it corrupt institutions which were
enriching people's private interests
called up their buddies in DC or their
dad and said this guy is getting in the
way to 10 for the big guy so we've got
Tony bobulinski this is one of the
hunter Biden Associates saying out right
he's in on it you've got the emails 10
percent held by by what does it say HB
for the big guy is that what it said was
that was that barisma though or is that
the China thing 10 for the big guy I
think was a China deal my point
specifically though is we can see in
these business dealings there is
evidence that Joe Biden is personally
benefiting we also have a text from
Hunter Biden where he said something the
effect of dad taking his salary or
things like that so he's acting as a
proxy for Joe Biden while Joe Biden was
in government Joe Biden personally goes
and gets the prosecutor fired who was
investigating the company where his son
was getting 83 000 a month there it is
Devin Archer testified before Congress
and and and the huge thing so so but
also real quick like if you just watch
that clip and just like like listen to
Joe Biden's tone in that clip like it's
like like he's just like acting like
he's like talking to like his nephew
he's just like bro like I don't know
brazenly bragging he's just like he's
like I gotta leave in about I gotta
leave in about six minutes you know I
got a flight to catch why don't you fire
that guy he's like he sounds like a like
a mafia guy who's like proud of like
that's just probably it really does
sound like a line written for like a a
mafia movie yeah he's like he's like
listen Joe if you don't fight a guy in
six minutes
yeah he's like talking just
publicly that's about what Trump was
impeached over that speaks to the way
that that politics in Washington DC is
handled generally though I mean or I I
would believe that would lead me to
believe because he doesn't he doesn't
think it's a he doesn't think it's a big
deal exactly it's no problem it's very
normal for him it comes off as you know
as you know obviously this is the case
yeah this is this wasn't the first time
that he behaved like that or whatever so
I mean it it it does speak to the the
the tenor and the way business is done
not just with Washington but obviously
internationally as well and the U.S if
the U.S has one of the less corrupt
governments on Earth which I don't know
for sure if it does or not but I know
there are places that are a real mess
but if if the US does have a less
corrupt government and that's the way
that business is handled uh among you
know someone that was the vice president
who'd been in in DC for 45 years at that
at that point or whatever then you know
that just imagine the rest of the world
yeah the rest of the world's a mess and
you know Ukraine is an absolute pigsty
because everyone knows that Ukraine is
is ex well everyone is aware of the the
root the the story or narrative that
Ukraine is one of the most corrupt
governments in the world 100 and and I I
don't know but I would assume Russia is
too but like
um that that's why you know it's it's so
crazy that like were involved in this
war in the first place because we're
talking about two very corrupt
um very authoritarian which we can get
into like you know pre-war zelinski's
authoritarian Tendencies but um like why
the U.S seems to think it needs to have
a dog in this fight of like
you know why do we care which corrupt uh
oligarch rules over Crimea or the Dome
boss it's like we shouldn't really care
they're both like horribly corrupt uh
countries to begin with but what's
interesting from this stuff and then
there was Chuck Grassley on the on the
senate floor uh the other day who talked
about one of these um I think barisma
Associates or one of Hunter Biden's
Associates in Ukraine had recorded
um 19 phone calls 17 with Hunter Biden
two with Joe Biden for the purpose of
blackmail this was Chuck Grassley saying
this I don't know if he produced any
like documentation for it but um you
know so and and why that's scary is like
could our president be blackmailed into
supporting this war
um yes and and the IDE and and World War
III is a real risk from this war so like
the implications of like I mean it's it
Russia is not viewing this as Russia
versus Ukraine their pundits all their
personalities are saying NATO versus
Russia so they're very much viewing this
as International conflict and it's only
the most naive or the most duplicitous
individuals who say we are not at war
with Russia we absolutely are you don't
get to provide weapons training military
and volunteers and then be like but we
have nothing to do with this war
yeah no and I agree and and it's even
worse because like I I think it's still
a majority we can maybe pull up the
polls if if they're up there but like
how many Americans still support
um the Ukraine war and I think it's a
majority and obviously these people
think you know we're fighting for
democracy we're fighting to protect
International borders but like if the
truth were to come out that like now
we're fighting because like they have
dirt on Joe Biden
and the the like we're literally risking
the entire world and they might have
okay there's the this is a Gallup from
one month ago 62 in June 2023 support
Ukraine reclaiming territory however it
is going down slowly slowly going down I
mean
um yeah I mean I I I I I I think
hopefully what would bring that bar to
the left
um more would be you know educating
people on the real reasons we're at War
and I don't know if it's because did
they have blackmail and Joe Biden no it
could just be geopolitical like
you know uh
you know
it is very much wanting to gain access
to energy right for Europe to expand the
European economy economy is stagnated if
you can supply weapons to Ukraine to
damage Russia's military that's good for
the U.S but but no no but yeah they say
that but I don't get why that's good for
the US like why why is like why is that
an end why is weakening Russia which by
the way means killing like young men on
the battlefield why is that an end to
the U.S and I I once
um I was on I don't know if we published
this but I was on um Capitol Hill and I
asked this to Dan Crenshaw he was like
Hey we're you know we're weakening a
strategic adversary and I was like well
why why are they a strategic adversary
and he was just like oh you're
pro-russia I'll see you later and it's
like no I'm just like I don't want to
blow up the world because they're a
bricks Nation they want to get off the
U.S Petro dollar they want to create
their own rival currency they're
starting to and the U.S views that as a
big threat Russia is the easier Target
out of the bunch China is too large so
in the meantime NATO expands presence in
Europe gains more control bolsters the
European economy to compete with the
Chinese economic Bloc and Russia being
the easier Target goes after them right
now but the funny thing is they didn't
used to be in bricks and they didn't
used to be trying to get another
currency like why were they our
strategic enemy ever I don't understand
after the Soviets fell it was like let
us go back in time I'm my friend yeah
let's go to 1993. what the hell's going
on yeah you keep going back it's never
just because the Soviet Union collapse
doesn't mean that these sentiments and
the people there were their worlds
changed for a lot of people the world
did change don't get me wrong but for
powerful individuals political leaders
and the oligarchs who are seizing
control they were born and bred of this
World East versus West so you can go all
the way back and keep going back in time
to find where the dawn of conflict
emerges but U.S interests competing with
foreign interests and the U.S has been
in many ways losing this in a lot of
ways and I think a lot of it has to do
with
there there is the fact that being a
constitutional republic weakens Us in
terms of uh executive action
the Chinese Communist Party snaps their
fingers and they get things done they
build a bridge overnight why because if
you don't do it you get locked into
Gulag or they're you know but then they
also build a bunch of empty apartment
buildings that have to get torn down
because you know Central planning
uh is you know it's inefficient or it's
you know it can you can you're at that
you're at the um sure but they're
talking about ghost cities they're using
a combination of the two they have so
this is this is an interesting uh merger
between the total communist
authoritarianism and having a little bit
of low tier low level economic activity
be allowed so this results in some kind
of capitalistic growth but you have got
to be a member of the party the party's
got to be in fascism your company yeah
essentially right yeah so the US I would
say you know my view of Joe Biden or any
of these presidents save Trump in my
lifetime it's the intelligence agencies
that are running everything and I think
it's fairly obvious and the way we've
always described it and even for Barack
Obama is that he's like when I get an
office we're gonna bring our troops back
and then as soon as he gets into office
he sits down and they go Mr President
and they slap the documents in front of
him and say this is why you'll do as
you're told and then anybody who says
otherwise they just slide a picture of
JFK right up and say once again this is
why you'll do what you're told so I do
think that I think the intelligence
agency is behind the scenes first most
of what we think we know is probably
wrong the news we're reading is probably
wrong come on we know they lie all the
time and we're still we're still trying
to base our perception on this war off
of all of this stuff and what Joe Biden
is doing I do think the people at the
CIA and the FBI want the us to win and
would prefer it if all of our lives were
better however in terms of conflict we
are just asked on a battlefield we are
economic numbers so Freedom doesn't
matter our rights doesn't matter the
Constitution doesn't matter all that
matters is the the global sphere of
influence for U.S and Western interest
but even if you're like you're at the
CIA and like you think in these terms
and like you you know you want to
maintain the petrol dollar which which
makes sense why you want to maintain the
petrodollar
um
but but the risks like they don't think
of the risks of like like why is the
Dome boss
worth risking nuclear war
um if you're the CIA
um
like it it could give Russia carte
blanche access to the Black Sea through
Crimea but if they if they really
solidify it that means that they're
gonna make turkey become their Ally and
that's a threat that turkey will leave
NATO because turkey is the exit from the
Black Sea into the Mediterranean turkey
if Turkey got out of NATO yeah it would
be it would be it would be that would be
the end of everything if Turkey leaves
NATO and joins bricks I mean we were
basically bifurcated the earth into two
hemispheres why do you say that well
because turkey control the phosphorus
yeah what they control the Bosphorus
they control the straight into the
Mediterranean from the Black Sea I mean
that's tons of economic activity for
Europe that will be can that is under
control of turkey so long as turkey is
working with NATO we have that Advantage
yeah but I mean I don't feel just having
just having meat turkey not in NATO
doesn't mean that turkey automatically
like will shut off the canal no no I
mean if if Turkey sides with bricks if
Turkey does say to the West you are now
on on the
let's just say the not nice end of the
stick
that's going to put more pressure on us
the issue with you know what I when I
look at Ukraine we got to go back and
the place I typically start and it goes
back much further than this obviously is
the cutter turkey pipeline Syria
the U.S and our interests in the Middle
East obviously were a conflict between
the US and Russia I mean even going back
to the mujahideen the support of these
groups so that they could fight the
Soviets Etc we are still in there for
very similar reasons why is it that
Syria falls into Civil War how
convenient for the United States when we
were facing obstruction for from Bashar
al-assad all of a sudden the country is
collapsing well we want to build the
pipeline pipeline would have gone to
Europe offset Russia's gas prom Monopoly
would have helped bolster energy energy
and expansion economic expansion in
Europe all of this stuff ties together
you then it's no surprise that there's a
counter-terrorism official from the CIA
a director who's now on the board of
barisma an energy company Hunter Biden
joins that board it's U.S interest to
stop the prosecutor investigating it
this is all about I think they're
looking at hard energy expansion
economic numbers they're saying we want
x amount of growth over this many years
they're looking at it like Russia is
growing at this space China's growing at
this pace they're working together if we
do not not have X amount of growth they
take over thucydidity's trap world war
three we lose Chinese Communist Party
wins okay but like so if you take a step
back even if you're still at the CIA
looking through their perspective and
you take a step back and you look at
like how things have gone over the last
like 20 years with all of these you know
regime change efforts we we undergo we
spend like trillions of dollars and we
just completely destroy these countries
that we were hoping to kind of control
and then you look at Afghanistan like we
we pull out anyway so it's like but
you're missing a bigger picture we don't
have a good track record do we do we
destroy the countries that agree to our
control
uh no the countries that bend the knee
and kiss the pinky ring we never hear
about invasions or coup d'etat or
anything like that because they did as
they were told it's the countries that
defy the us and not just the U.S but
Western powers that face these you know
we came we saw he died is that what
that's that's how Hillary Clinton
described it about Gaddafi yeah you know
so a reason will be made and the people
who don't fall in line do as they're
told well oh so what I was going to say
is like
if because you kind of said the goal is
like control and money
um which I guess are two different
things but if like if they just wanted
money if like this if like
the people at these defense companies
and and you know CIA wherever want money
it's like why don't they just
I mean like we spent we spent well I
thought you said that but I economic
expansion right they they want to see
the sphere of influence of Western
Nations expand and maintain a unipolar
domination in the planet on the planet
on Earth China is pushing that boundary
and we are we are now very likely I
think it's safe to say we are a
multi-polar world meaning we now have
the rise of of multiple superpowers
which brings the very real risk of of
mass competent war after World War II we
saw the rise of the liberal economic
order the intention was to prevent this
from happening again you know they tried
it with the League of Nations United
Nations they want well but okay so on
that point they want they created it to
prevent this from happening again but
now the evidence seems overwhelming that
like it's the driving force for why it's
happening again always and so it's
there's no there's no there's no simple
answer to this exercise is has been like
difficult for me because my brain does
not work I imagine like any of these
people at the CIA but like why they need
to dominate and influence the entire
world when it's like look at like look
at this amazing land mass we have over
here on like you know the Western
Hemisphere it's like why can't we just
like enjoy this and live on our farm and
like take it easy especially these guys
at the top
but they've made the argument very clear
China will not stop they're trying to
take the South China Sea they're
building military bases on these yeah
but they're not going to come here
they're not going to come here well but
what about Alaska what about the
aleutians it's a question of will they
come here or will they expand their
influence into Africa which they're
already doing South America that's like
the Belton Road initiative and then all
of a sudden in the U.S we are
constrained and can't get access to
certain resources that is their View and
they say it plainly I'm not saying
they're right but they've made their
argument but also Belton Road is like in
like military bases like Belton Road is
them like you know getting countries in
debt which you can say is like Western
model right but yeah but but I mean like
they're building infrastructure or
they're like influencing them to like
you know on International to vote with
them on International organizations but
like they only have like
um I think they only have like two or
three foreign military bases and they're
like artificial islands near China we
have military bases all over that's what
I'm saying is like why are we so worried
about China when they don't yet have all
these foreign military bases that's why
because they're expanding it's kind of
like but not militarily but they are and
you're saying it's a small number but
that doesn't matter what matters is they
are that's it the intelligence agency
but we have troops in Taiwan we have
troops in the Philippines and base not
an article but it's like why do you
think they're doing it maybe because
maybe we could talk to them and say hey
guys don't build this base on this
artificial Island we'll pull our troops
out of Taiwan you know what I mean the
you so negotiations could happen to
prevent it as opposed to like right
right but you're not making you're not
making an argument it's this it's simple
there's a unipolar power structure where
the West controls things through
economics and through conflict and those
that don't fall in line Hillary Clinton
we came we saw he died that's what
happens China starts expanding Russia
teams up with them this is a threat it
doesn't matter if they've if it doesn't
matter if the guy across the street
threw one rock at you the moment he does
you call the police and say I will not I
will not stand for this now you can
argue that the guy with the rock threw
to the guy who's got 17 tanks and a
bunch of RPGs lined up but either way
they're going to be like oh he's
throwing rocks at us right China is
expanding in certain areas their
influence is growing their economy is
growing it is a threat to the U.S we are
now facing a multi-polar world and the
the the the these uh I I view it like
after World War II you get the liberal
economic order you get these powerful
Elites who are like we are going to use
this position to control everything and
prevent this from happening they pass it
down to their kids Next Generation Who
start to slowly screw things up who pass
it down to their kids who have no idea
what the hell they're doing and have
fumbled the whole thing and now we are
facing a a massive crisis but these
people inherited this they don't know
better so they're just thinking we
better fight this war to prevent it from
happening somewhere else and you're like
okay well look there's two outcomes I
suppose the parent tree is
we do nothing the acidity's Trap
dictates the likelihood of World War III
is tremendous and then War happens or we
just start it all now pushback and hope
that holding back Russia from the Don
bass and putting pressure on China stops
the expansion and we don't end up in a
suit in a thucydidity strip
yeah I I you know I don't I I I don't I
don't see well in Ukraine specifically
like do you see Russia well certainly
not Crimea I think there's no shot
Russia leaves Crimea there's two million
Russian civilians who live there and
then and and it's it's basically been
Russia uh we had I think it was Dave
Smith but they I think was Dave Smith
who mentioned Russia didn't invade and
take over Crimea yeah they stepped out
the door of the military base said hi
guys I think like three people died or
something but it's not that the point is
that they already had a military
presence of them I know so they didn't
they it was that they walked out of the
military base and said how's it going
everybody we're right I think they've
actually had that base for hundreds of
years that's right um but so
it like and then hope I just hope
there's people in the U.S who like
understand that and are like oh yeah
we're just waiting to play that card of
like nobody knows
what do you mean you you go talk to the
average person average liberal look man
no no I'm talking about people in the
top brass yeah the the challenge with
those who support all this is that you
go and ask any liberal who's waving a
Ukrainian flag and they won't be able to
tell you the first thing they can't
point to Ukraine on a map yeah I mean
that that yeah that I mean that was the
whole Dan Crenshaw thing I'm just saying
I'm pro-russia when I tried to ask him
you know what it's just like it was like
the war with Iraq and an invasion of
Afghanistan it was like are you with the
terrorists are you with us it's like
dude you want to invade a foreign
country and kill their leader I got
questions and they're like well then you
support the terrorists no shut up yeah
but that's what they go for because the
average person doesn't care doesn't want
to care and doesn't want to pay
attention they want to they want to play
their games they want to watch their
shows they want to see Taylor Swift they
don't want to deal with this stuff yeah
I don't blame them thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time